Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the, bringing the earth and sky together into one swaying blur. The snow fell on bark's shoulders. It was as though flakes of silence were falling on the still vulgar, on the dead city, on the skeletons of horses. It was snowing everywhere, on earth and on the stars. The whole universe was full of snow. Everything was disappearing beneath it. Guns, the bodies of the dead, filthy dressings, rubble, scraps of twisted iron. This soft white snow settling over the carnage of the city was time itself. The present was turning into the past and there was no future. Welcome to The Rest is History and that was Vasily Grossman
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入。天地化作一片摇曳的模糊。白雪落在了树皮的肩膀上。雪花仿佛落在死寂的庸俗、死去的城市、以及马匹骨骸之上的寂静碎片。大地上，星空下，到处都在下雪。整个宇宙都充满了雪。一切都在它下面消失。枪支、死者的尸体、污秽的绷带、瓦砾、扭曲的铁块。这层厚厚的白雪覆盖在这座城市的屠场上，它就是时间本身。现在正在变成过去，而未来已不复存在。欢迎收听《历史的 rest》，刚才这段是瓦西里·格罗斯曼
in his great novel Life and Fate drawing on his experience as a war reporter during the Battle of Stalingrad in the last months of 1942. So, Tom, we ended the last episode with German and Soviet troops fighting house to house, and winter was coming over closer, and our guest Ian McGregor is still with us. And Ian, can we kick off by talking about one of the really iconic things about Stalingrad, something I know you're really interested in,
在他的伟大长篇小说《生活与命运》中，取材于他在1942年最后几个月斯大林格勒战役期间担任战地记者的亲身经历。所以，汤姆，我们在上一集的结尾讲到德国和苏联军队在进行挨家挨户的巷战，冬天也越来越近了，我们的嘉宾伊恩·麦格雷戈仍然和我们在一起。伊恩，我们可以从斯大林格勒最具标志性的事物之一开始聊起吗？我知道你对这个非常感兴趣，
which is the story of Pavlov and his house. Because this is, your book is called The Lighthouse of Stalingrad. And, I mean, obviously, it's a podcast, so people can't see the map, and his house because this is your book is called the lighthouse of stalingrad and um i mean obviously this is a podcast so people can't see the map but if you can imagine there is a a square very close to the volga river called the 9th of january square and it's flanked by all these buildings um the german forces uh have sort of got down to the square and there's one building that sort of sticks out into the square isn't there's one building that sort of sticks out into the square,
那就是巴甫洛夫和他的房子的故事。因为这是，你的书叫《斯大林格勒的灯塔》。我的意思是，显然，这是一档播客，所以大家看不到地图，而且他的房子——因为你的书叫《斯大林格勒的灯塔》，呃，我的意思是，显然这是一个播客，所以人们看不到地图，但如果你能想象得到，在伏尔加河附近有一个广场，叫做“1月9日广场”，周围环绕着所有这些建筑，呃，德军，呃，差不多已经推进到了广场边缘，有一栋建筑在广场上格外显眼，不是吗？有一栋建筑在广场上格外显眼，
isn't it? It's an apartment building. And this is the building that becomes famous, the famous building of Stalingrad called Pavlov's House. So tell us about who Pavlov is and why his house matters. Junior Sergeant Pavlov is a bit like Chukov. He was born in a village outside of Moscow, about 50 miles outside of Moscow.
对吧？那是一栋公寓楼。这就是那栋名声大噪、被称为“巴甫洛夫之屋”的斯大林格勒著名建筑。那么给我们讲讲巴甫洛夫是谁，以及为什么他的房子这么重要。中士巴甫洛夫有点像朱可夫。他出生在莫斯科郊外的一个村子里，距离莫斯科大约50英里。
He joined up at the start of the war. And he was in the elite formations because the guards rifle divisions that had been created were seen as the elite of the Russian Red Army Armed Forces. Better train, better equipment, better pay, better food. And he was in Redimtsev's 13th Guards that had gone over on this suicidal, almost like Omaha Beach assault onto the Western Shore to reclaim the central part of the city, which the Germans had taken the day before. And they did manage to drive them back. And then what you have therefore going forward over the next few weeks and months is this brutal house-to-house fighting for just the few inches of ground, few feet of ground,
他在战争刚爆发时就参战了。他属于精锐部队，因为当时组建的近卫步兵师被视为俄国红军武装力量的精锐。更好的训练、更好的装备、更好的薪水、更好的伙食。他隶属于罗季姆采夫的第13近卫师，该师曾进行过这种近乎自杀式的、类似于奥马哈海滩登陆的突击，强渡到西岸，以收复德国人头一天占领的城市中心区。他们的确成功把敌人赶了回去。因此，在接下来的几周和几个月里，这里发生的就是残酷的巷战，为了仅仅几英寸、几英尺的土地，
the next room, the next floor, hopefully you capture the next building. The 9th of January Square is literally 600, 700 metres away from the Volga and behind that is the central landing pier where the main supplies of troops and ammunition and as well as the wounded going in the other direction were. And that's where Radimtsev had his headquarters. And it was up to him to have his three regiments
为了下一个房间、下一层楼，如果幸运的话，就能攻占下一栋建筑。“1月9日广场”距离伏尔加河只有600、700米远，其后方就是中央登陆码头，部队和弹药的主要补给以及运往反方向的伤员都是从这里进出的。这也是罗季姆采夫设立指挥部的地方。他必须让他的三个团
along this line that would defend the pockets of resistance in the center of the city. And what evolved was it was the case of following Chukev's orders that there would be an active defense, which came all the way from Moscow. Stalin wanted to see this. He wanted to let the Russian people know that they were fighting to defend the city and they were taking the fight to the Germans. They weren't just passively waiting to be attacked. So this active defense spawned or evolved the doctrine of the storm troops. Pavlov became part of this. Instead of mass assaults by company-sized formations, which would then be decimated by German artillery, assault guns, or aerial attacks, they would shrink this down to six-man teams. Normally,
沿这条防线展开，以防守城市中心的抵抗据点。随之演变出来的是，根据朱可夫从莫斯科下达的命令，要进行积极防御。斯大林非常希望看到这一点。他想让俄罗斯人民知道，他们正在为保卫城市而战，他们正在主动向德国人发起进攻。他们不只是被动地等待挨打。因此，这种积极防御催生或演变出了突击队战术。巴甫洛夫也成了其中的一部分。不再是以连级建制进行的大规模冲锋——这种冲锋随后会被德国炮兵、突击炮或空袭撕成碎片，而是将兵力缩减为六人小组。通常，
six-man teams could be eight-man teams, and they would be armed to the teeth. So they would shrink this down to six-man teams. Normally six-man teams could be eight-man teams. And they would be armed to the teeth. So they would have the latest submachine guns, like I was saying, their pocket artillery, which was bags of grenades. And it would be up to them to be the vanguard to see if they could take these buildings that were further into the heart of the city that might be able to allow Radimtsev to then push the line further away from the Volga and give himself more of a chance of staying there.
六人小组也可以是八人小组，而且他们会武装到牙齿。所以他们会将兵力缩减为六人小组。通常六人小组也可以是八人小组。并且他们会武装到牙齿。因此，他们将配备最新的冲锋枪，正如我所说，还有他们的口袋炮——也就是一袋袋的手榴弹。他们将作为先锋，去看看能否攻占那些更深入城市核心地带的建筑，从而让罗季姆采夫得以将防线进一步推离伏尔加河，为自己留在那里创造更多胜算。
So from late September all the way through to the end, really, that's the kind of fighting that the Russians employed in the heart of the city and in the factory districts to retake these buildings. So Pavlov was just part of this. And the house that Dominic was talking about was a house that stuck out. It was a huge four-story apartment block. It could probably take at least 200 people, had over 100 rooms, had a reinforced concrete basement as well. And before the war, it had been one of these new modern blocks that had been built for specialists who
因此，从9月下旬一直到最后，这基本上就是俄军在市中心和工厂区用来收复这些建筑的战斗方式。所以巴甫洛夫只是其中的一部分。多米尼克刚才提到的那栋房子是一栋突出的建筑。那是一栋巨大的四层公寓楼。它至少能容纳200人，有一百多个房间，还有一个钢筋混凝土的地下室。在战前，它是为那些在工厂区工作的专家、
worked in the factory districts, the middle managers, directors, and important party officials. So before the war, it was a place you wanted to live in. But during the war, no. Yes, exactly. By the war, no. And so the Germans had taken it. It was one of their main places that they had taken around the square. They already had all the buildings on the other side of the square and to the side of the square as well. And this building was seen as a, I suppose, it was a vantage point because it was so high. And it becomes a totem.
中层管理者、厂长以及重要的党政官员建造的新式现代公寓之一。所以在战前，那是个你想住进去的地方。但在战争期间，那就不是了。是的，没错。到战争时期，就不是了。因此德国人占领了它。这是他们在广场周围占领的主要据点之一。他们已经控制了广场另一侧以及广场侧面的所有建筑。这栋建筑被视为一个——我想，由于它很高，它成了一个极佳的观察点。并且它变成了一个图腾。
Yes, exactly. And it offered great views across the city. You could see the whole length of the city. You could see what the Germans were doing in terms of where they were moving to. It would give the artillery spotters on the roof time to then feed back information to the huge artillery parks that Chuikov had built on the eastern shore that were landing these huge salvos that were destroying German formations. As they lined up, even before they attacked, they would be spotted. And this is one of the reasons why the Germans wanted this kind of house back. So when they lost it to Pavlov's team, and then it became infested with reinforcements and turned into a super fortress, the Germans wanted it back. And that's a very similar story to at least a dozen buildings you could talk about in the centre of the city that was fought over, back and forth over the following months.
是的，正好。它提供了俯瞰全城的绝佳视野。你能看到城市的整个长度。你可以看到德国人在移动位置方面的动向。这能为屋顶上的炮兵观察员争取时间，将信息实时反馈给朱可夫在东岸建立的庞大炮兵群，从而倾泻出巨大的齐射火力，摧毁德国人的阵型。当他们排好队甚至还没发动进攻时，就会被发现。这就是德国人想要夺回这种房子的原因之一。因此，当他们把房子失守给巴甫洛夫的突击队，并且这里被增援部队塞满、变成了一座超级堡垒后，德国人就更想把它夺回来了。这与你在市中心能聊到的至少十多栋争夺过的建筑的故事非常相似，在接下来的几个月里，双方为了它们反复易手。
So when you say a super fortress, they're installing machine guns. I mean, the whole place must have been shot to pieces, but it's basically a ruin by now, right? Absolutely. Yeah. I mean, the roof's pretty much caved in. Obviously, all the windows are shot out. And it's become a kind of totem for the Soviets. Is it also something that the Germans feel we've got to take it? Well, that's what I found in the research. It was never, again, if you look at the official story, Paulus himself apparently had it marked on his map that Pavlov's house was a place that they needed to take. But it's not mentioned in any combat diary of the main German divisions,
所以当你说是超级堡垒时，他们是在里面安装机枪。我的意思是，整个地方肯定被打得稀巴烂了，但到目前为止它基本上就是一片废墟了，对吧？完全正确。是的。我的意思是，屋顶基本上已经塌了。显然，所有的窗户都被打碎了。它成了苏联人的一种图腾。这也是德国人觉得我们必须把它夺下来的目标吗？嗯，这就是我在研究中发现的。它从来都不是——同样，如果你看官方说法，保卢斯本人显然在地图上将巴甫洛夫之屋标记为一个他们需要攻占的地方。但这并没有在主要德国师的任何作战日记中被提及，
the two or three German divisions that were operating in that area. They never talked about it. The main combat commander whose personal papers I discovered, who was a key figure in the fighting in this area, never mentioned it. He talked about other buildings that they fought for, but he didn't talk about Pavlov's house. Don't get me wrong, it was essential. They needed to have it. It was almost their warning system for anything that would happen if the Germans were going to advance towards Radimsev's main line. He needed that as his almost canary in the gas chamber
也就是在那个地区活动的两三个德国师。他们从未谈论过它。我发现了其个人文件的主要战地指挥官——他是该地区战斗中的关键人物——也从未提及它。他谈到了他们争夺过的其他建筑，但没有谈论巴甫洛夫之屋。别误会我，它至关重要。他们需要得到它。它几乎是他们的预警系统，用来防范任何可能发生的德国人向罗季姆采夫主力防线推进的行动。他需要这个据点，几乎就像毒气室里的金丝雀一样，
to warn him what was going on. But you're right, Tom, they'd laid minefields around the building. It was heavily barbed wire. They'd moved in heavy machine guns. They'd moved in teams of tank destroyers on the roof. It was pretty impregnable. So why, I mean, Pavlov's house becomes famous, doesn't it? Is it famous during the battle or is it only famous afterwards?
来向他发出警报。但你说得对，汤姆，他们在建筑物周围布下了雷区。那里有密集的铁丝网。他们部署了重机枪。他们在屋顶上部署了反坦克小组。它几乎坚不可摧。那么，为什么——我的意思是，巴甫洛夫之屋变得闻名遐迩，不是吗？它是在战役期间就出名了，还是只有在战后才出名的？
Because I think, isn't it taken up by a newspaper called Stalin's Banner? Great name for a newspaper. Tell where that's coming from. I think its political leanings are very clear. So Stalin's Banner is basically the Russian Guardian. I'm right in thinking that this is long after the battle and it basically creates Pavlov's house as a kind of an emblem of Soviet fellowship and bravery. Because it's all about how it's not just Russians, is it?
因为我想，它是不是被一份叫做《斯大林旗帜》的报纸报道了？报纸的名字真棒。说说这报纸的来历吧。我想它的政治倾向非常明确。所以《斯大林旗帜》基本上就是俄国版的《卫报》。我这样想没错吧：这发生在战役结束很久之后，它基本上把巴甫洛夫之屋塑造成了苏联友谊和英勇的某种象征？因为这关系到它不仅是俄罗斯人，对吧？
It's people from across the Soviet Union. It's a band of happy brothers. The Red Army during the Second World War really expanded their propaganda tentacles into their formations. There was over 1,300 newspapers and journals published, created and published across the Red Army, across every territory.
它是来自整个苏联各地的人。这是一群快乐的兄弟。二战期间的红军确实将他们的宣传触角深入到了各个部队中。红军内部出版、创办了1300多份报纸和期刊，覆盖各个战区。
So that's where you've got people like Ilya Ehrenberg and Valery Gr Grossman and these sort of iconic figures. Yeah, I mean, there were over, I think, 5,000 reporters that would work on these journals and newspapers. And of that 5,000, over 900 were professional writers, as Ehrenberg and obviously Vasily Grossman. So they were part of this organised, dedicated setup to report the stories that boosted morale, gave any kind of defeat a certain slant that it didn't seem so catastrophic.
所以这就是伊利亚·埃伦堡和瓦列里·格罗斯曼以及这些标志性人物出现的地方。是的，我的意思是，有超过，我想，有5000名记者在这些期刊和报纸上工作。在这5000人中，有900多名是专业作家，比如埃伦堡和显赫的瓦西里·格罗斯曼。因此，他们是有组织、有奉献精神的团队的一部分，负责报道那些能够提振士气、并给任何失败涂抹上一层色彩使其看起来不那么灾难性的故事。
And Stalingrad, as you said, right at the beginning, became a metaphor for almost the soul of the Russian during that part of the Great Patriotic War. We cannot give Stalin up. It's a breathing, living city. It's not a dead city. We are fighting for it. We are fighting for the soul. And we are defending Mother Russia and Mother Volga. And that's the kind of attitude that was taken. So Ian, I listened to the podcast that our sister podcast, We Have Ways, did on Stalingrad. And they had an interview with a very interesting, I think, creator of the museum, the Second World War in Dresden. And he scoffed at the idea. We don't have scoffing on our podcast, Tom.
正如你在一开始所说，斯大林格勒在伟大的卫国战争的那段时期，几乎变成了俄罗斯人灵魂的隐喻。我们不能放弃斯大林。它是一座有呼吸、有生命的城市。它不是一座死城。我们正在为它而战。我们在为灵魂而战。我们在保卫俄罗斯母亲和伏尔加母亲。这就是当时采取的态度。所以，伊恩，我听了我们的姐妹播客《我们有办法》制作的关于斯大林格勒的播客。他们采访了一位非常有趣的、我想是德累斯顿二战博物馆的创建者。他对这种观点嗤之以鼻。汤姆，我们播客里不兴嗤之以鼻。
Well, he didn't scoff. He was politely sceptical of the idea that Stalingrad had resonance for the Soviets and for Stalin himself because it was Stalin City, because of its name. What's your take on that? I think I would say inside the city, those that were fighting for it, definitely I would agree with that. I think they weren't fighting for Stalin. They weren't fighting for any kind of notional idea that they were saving Russia. I think as any combat soldiers would say, fighting in any kind of horrific situation like this, they're fighting for each other. You're doing it for your friends. But the broader, the propaganda thing, the spin, how is the Soviet press, how is the Soviet media spinning it?
好吧，他没有嗤之以鼻。他只是对斯大林格勒对苏联人和斯大林本人具有共鸣——因为它是斯大林城，因为它的名字——这种观点抱有礼貌的怀疑。你对此有何看法？我想我会说，在城市内部，那些为之战斗的人，我绝对同意这一点。我认为他们不是为了斯大林而战。他们不是为了拯救俄罗斯的某种虚幻概念而战。我想，正如任何参加过战斗的士兵所说，在这样一种恐怖的环境中作战，他们是在为彼此而战。你这么做是为了你的朋友。但更广泛的层面，宣传的东西、粉饰，苏联报刊、苏联媒体是如何进行粉饰的？
The story was taken up on the 31st of October. It was first mentioned. By then, the battle had moved to the north, the factory district. The south of the city had already been captured weeks before. The central part was pretty much 90% occupied by the Germans. There was only that sliver of a few hundred meters depth from the Volga that was still occupied by Radimtsev's forces. Paulus was now under instruction that you've taken those two bits.
这个故事是在10月31日被采纳的。它第一次被提及。到那时，战役已经转移到了北部，也就是工厂区。南部城区几周前就已经被占领了。中部地区基本上90%被德国人占领。只剩下伏尔加河边几百米深狭长地带仍然被罗季姆采夫的部队占据。保卢斯现在接到指示，既然你们已经拿下了这两部分，
The final bit is to now take the factory district. And that's where the fighting had moved to. So Pavlov's house and the 9th of January Square was quite quiet at the time. And that's when the reporters, I suppose, felt it safe to move in and do some interviews. And that's exactly what happened. So as I say in the book, this correspondent for the newspaper, six-page newspaper or newsletter for the 62nd Army was called Stalin's Banner. And a lieutenant, Julie Shapurin, happened to be given permission to go into the house. And he was the one who actually gave the term in the first article about it on the 31st of October, the House of Pavlov.
最后一部任务就是拿下工厂区。战斗已经转移到了那里。所以当时的巴甫洛夫之屋和1月9日广场相当平静。就在那时，记者们——我想——觉得进去做几次采访是安全的。事实也的确如此。正如我在书中所写的那样，第62集团军这份六页报纸或简讯的通讯员名叫《斯大林旗帜》。一位中尉尤利·沙普林恰巧获准进入这栋房子。他在10月31日关于它的第一篇文章中，实际创造了“巴甫洛夫之屋”这个称呼。
And in that, he then waxes lyrical about the tropes that have survived all these decades long, about there was a few of them. They were a band of brothers. They came from this huge ethnic mix that represented the Soviet Union. So Tatars, Chechens, Tajiks, and ironically Ukrainians, that would hold off this relentless horde of German infantry, aerial attacks, and armoured attacks for the next 58 days. And is this rubbish, ultimately?
在那篇报道中，他随后饱含激情地大谈那些流传了数十年的老套路：这里只有几个人。他们是生死之交。他们来自代表苏联的巨大民族大熔炉。所以有鞑靼人、车臣人、塔吉克人，还有具有讽刺意味的乌克兰人，他们阻挡了德国步兵、空袭和装甲部队那无休止的狂潮长达58天。这最终是不是胡扯？
It's inflated. It happened to a degree. But like any fight that was going on in the city, as we talked about earlier on, you capture a house or you capture a room or a floor in a house, you might give it up within 12 hours and then you might retake it again. And this goes back and forward, back and forward, over the days and the weeks of this fighting and that's why it became a meat grinder the house itself uh they took it but by my reading of the accounts that were written down and just stored in in the panorama museum's archives and that's not just the the ordinary soldiers who
这是被夸大了。它在某种程度上确实发生过。但就像城里发生的任何战斗一样，正如我们之前讨论过的，你攻下一栋房子，或者攻下一栋房子里的一个房间或一层楼，你可能在12小时内就会失守，然后你可能又会把它夺回来。这种争夺在战斗的日子和星期里反反复复，这也是为什么它成了一个绞肉机。至于房子本身，呃，他们占领了它，但根据我的理解，那些被记录下来并存放在全景博物馆档案中的记录来看——这不仅包括与巴甫洛夫并肩作战的普通士兵，还包括他的指挥官，以及一直到负责该地区作战的团级指挥链——他们调集了大量军队。这就是他们把它变成堡垒的方式。这也是他们把其他房屋变成堡垒的方式。其核心重点是，是的，他们会来进攻我们。而且他们主要会通过空袭来进攻我们，因为那是他们最好的武器，还有炮火齐射，这确实会造成伤亡；但一旦伤亡人员被运送出去，就会有更多的增援部队开进来。所以这其实不是什么生死之交，它
fought with pavlov but his commanding officer and then the chain of command right up to regimental level that was in charge of operations in the area. They moved in a lot of troops. That's how they turned it into a fortress. And that's how they were turning the other houses into fortresses. The whole point of which was, yes, they're going to attack us. And primarily they're going to attack us via aerial attack because that was that was their best weapon and and artillery barrages and that does cause casualties but as soon as the the casualties were shipped out more reinforcements come in so it's not really a band of brothers it's
是一个，它是一个不断变化的——是的，它很同质，有大量的军队。巴甫洛夫本人，我没记错的话，巴甫洛夫是指挥官吗？指挥官是一个叫阿法纳西耶夫的人，阿法纳西耶夫中尉？是的。所以在巴甫洛夫的突击队占领这栋房子48小时内他就进驻了。同样，关于他们究竟是不是通过战斗占领这栋房子的，也有各种猜测。我读过的一些德国史料显示，当时那里其实根本没人。德国人已经撤出了。不过这故事听起来就没那么精彩了，对吧？正是如此。但传说他们确实在那里，并且挨个房间进行了战斗并取得了成功。所以阿法纳西耶夫在48小时后接管了这里。
a it's a it's a shifting yes it's homogenous there's an awful lot of troops and pavlov himself am i right in thinking that pavlov't the commander? The commander was a man called Afanasyev, Lieutenant Afanasyev? Yeah. So he came in within 48 hours of Pavlov's storm team taking the house. And again, there's conjecture on whether they actually took the house by fighting. Some German stories I've read is there was actually no one there. The Germans had vacated it. That's not such a good story though, is it? Exactly. But the legend is they were there and they took it room by room and they succeeded. So Anasayev took over 48 hours later.
他是带领第一批增援部队进入这座房子的人。所以，伊恩，这就是一个绞肉机。德军和苏军在互相撕扯。似乎没有发生什么大事，除了每个人都在死去。但随后确实发生了变化。这就是“天王星行动”。是的。其实早在9月初那段最黑暗的日子里，当德国人首次对这座城市实施合围并将其夷为废墟时，就已经开始讨论这个计划了。当时朱可夫甚至还没有被授予指挥权。这就是格奥尔吉·朱可夫。
He was the one who led the first of a number of reinforcement columns into the house. So Ian, it's a meat grinder. The Germans and the Russians are kind of tearing chunks out of each other. Nothing much seems to be happening except that everyone's dying. But then something does change. And this is Operation Uranus. Yes. So this had been actually first talked about during the really dark days of early September when the Germans were first investing the city and they'd already reduced it to rubble. And it was a case of, and Zhukov hadn't even been given his command yet. And this was Georgy Zhukov.
当时他还不是朱可夫元帅。一年左右后他才会成为元帅，但当时他是一名将军，不过他仍然是副最高统帅，而且他是向莫斯科的斯大林汇报的人。他和同僚华西列夫斯基一起，概述了他们所处的困境：德国人仍在向伏尔加河推进，他们将要攻占斯大林格勒。除了挨了斯大林的一顿训斥——斯大林显然不愿意看到这种情况发生——他们还拥有——
At the time, he wasn't Marshal Zhukov yet. He would be a year or so later, but at the time he was a general, but he was still Deputy Supreme Commander and he was the one reporting to Stalin in Moscow. And with his colleague Vasilevsky, they were outlining the predicament they were in and the Germans were still pushing towards the Volga and they were going to seize Stalingrad. And as well as getting a flea in their ear from Stalin, who obviously didn't want to have this happen, they had the –
我是说他们有魄力，他们有能力让斯大林坐下来，作为军事战略家——他们两人都是伟大的军事战略家——向他提及他们有这样一套计划。他们能看出，从德国人出发的基地算起，他们的战线现在已经拉得太长了。而且他们的两翼非常薄弱。所以关键在于卡车。一切都在于卡车。正如人们所说，正如关于卡车的，向伏尔加河推进的主力战斗是由德国军队、步兵和装甲部队以及我刚才提到的空军完成的，但他们的两翼是由他们的轴心国盟友掩护的。
I was going to say the guts, they had the ability to actually sit him down and mention that they had this plan as military strategists, great military strategists, both of them were, they could see how overextended the German lines were now from their main base where they'd started from. And they had very weak flanks. So it's all about the trucks. It's all about the trucks. Also about the trucks, as had been said, the bulk of the fighting going towards the Volga was being done by German troops, infantry and armour, and the Luftwaffe, like I said, but their flanks were being guarded by their Axis allies.
而他们的轴心国盟友并不强大，对吧？他们并不强大。他们有着顽强的战斗精神。这就是我在阅读的大量记录中所看到的。显然，当“天王星行动”开始时，他们中的许多人确实逃跑了。但如果你是冰封大草原上的一个步兵，几周来都没有吃饱饭，也没有击退T-34所必须的反坦克炮，当你看到成百上千辆坦克穿过雾霭驶来时，你会怎么做？他们在北部第一阶段开始时确实进行了为期一天或两天的抵抗。但这毕竟是数量和火力的优势。他们主要是罗马尼亚人。他们是罗马尼亚人、匈牙利人吗？主要是罗马尼亚人负责掩护两翼，
And their Axis allies are not strong, right? They're not strong. They had great fighting spirit. And that's what I've seen in a lot of the records I've read. I mean, obviously, a lot of them did flee when Uranus started. But if you're an infantryman on the frozen steppe, and you haven't been fed properly in weeks, and you haven't got the anti-tank guns you're required to fend off a T-34, when you see hundreds of them coming through the foggy mist, What do you do? And they did put up a fight for a day or two days, I think, in the north when the first section started. But it's a weight of numbers and a weight of firepower. They're mostly Romanians. Are they Romanians, Hungarians? Primarily Romanians were guarding the flanks
意大利人和匈牙利人也在其中。但占压倒性比例的、最著名的是，在初期战线被突破的主要是负责两翼掩护的罗马尼亚人，特别是北部。但伊恩，你刚才说是坦克，不过从你的书中我还了解到，还有哥萨克骑兵。很棒的恐吓战术。而且他们在雪地里行动自如。他们物资充足。
with Italians and the Hungarians too. But predominantly, famously, the main breaks in the line at the beginning were from the Romanians that were guarding the flanks, in the north especially. But Ian, you said it was tanks, but also I gather from your book, Cossack horse cavalry. Great scare tactic. And they can travel well in snow. They're well-provisioned.
是的，成千上万的哥萨克纵队。所以，我的意思是，我完全不知道在斯大林格勒战役中，他们物资充足。是的，成千上万的哥萨克纵队。所以，我的意思是，我完全不知道在斯大林格勒战役中，哥萨克的骑兵发挥了关键作用。嗯，那是在草原上。不是在城市里。是在外面的草原上。因为你得记住，这条前线绵延数百英里。所以这是一个合围的过程。
Yeah, thousands upon thousands of Cossack columns. So, I mean, I had no idea that at the Battle of Stalingrad, They're well-provisioned. Yeah, thousands upon thousands of Cossack columns. So, I mean, I had no idea that at the Battle of Stalingrad, the Cossacks on their horses played a key role. Well, that's in the step. It's not in the city itself. It's out on the step. Because you've got to remember, this frontier ran for hundreds of miles. So this is the encircling process.
所以他们从周围包抄过来，有点像把德国人装进瓶子里。你可以把它与坎尼战役——汉尼拔对罗马人的伟大胜利——相提并论。但在坎尼，汉尼拔的军队比他们包围的罗马军队要小。但据推测，到了斯大林格勒战役的这个阶段，俄国人在数量上已经开始真正压倒德国人了吧？是的。是的。我的意思是，那是他们的增援部队真正投入战场的时候。他们被源源不断地投入到朱可夫在城市南北两侧的两翼建立的大型桥头堡中，不仅是兵力。到那时他们已经拥有远超一百万的军队，都是生力军，包括哥萨克。
So they're coming around and they're kind of bottling the Germans up. And you compare it to the Battle of Cannes, Hannibal's great victory over the Romans. But at Cannes, Hannibal's army was smaller than the Roman army that they envelop. But presumably by this point at Stalingrad, the Russians are starting to really outnumber the Germans, are they? Yes. Yeah. I mean, that's when their reinforcements are really coming online. They're being fed into the mix of the big bridgeheads that Zhukov was building up on either flank, north and south of the city, not just in terms of men. They had well over a million men by now, fresh troops, including Cossacks.
但他拥有数百辆坦克，而且他们重建了苏联空军。所以他们现在拥有远超一千架飞机，能够在城市上空以及他们将从南北两翼进行钳形攻势的目标区域内争夺制空权。那么，在“天王星行动”开始后多久，德国人发现自己被包围了？几天之内。行动于19号在北部发起，次日从南部发起。到23号，他们在一个交通枢纽卡拉奇胜利会师，这里深入德国防线大约40到50公里，
But he had hundreds of tanks and they'd rebuilt the Soviet Air Force. So they had well over a thousand planes now that could contest the skies over the city as well as in and around the areas that they were going to attack in a pincer movement from north and south. And so how long after starting Operation Uranus did the Germans find themselves surrounded? Within days. So it was launched in the north on the 19th, the following day from the south. And by the 23rd, they met up famously at a transport hub, Kalach, which was roughly around 40 to 50 kilometres deep into the German lines
远远位于斯大林格勒后方。他们就是在那里会合的。也就是在那里，德国人意识到自己陷入了进退维谷的境地。德国人对此完全措手不及吗？他们一点也没察觉到吗？他们收到过一些警告，但我不认为他们意识到了。在希特勒运筹帷幄的高层指挥阶层中，并不相信对方不仅有进攻的资源，而且会效仿德国人使用合成兵力的战术。这是俄国人真正意义上第一次使用合成兵力。空袭配合随之而来的巨大炮火轰炸。然后装甲部队突击，接着步兵
and way behind Stalingrad. And that's where they met. And that's where the Germans realised they were in a tricky situation. And are the Germans taken completely by surprise by this? Have they not seen it coming at all? They'd had some warnings, but I don't think they realised. There wasn't a belief in the upper echelons of the high command where Hitler was operating, that they would have not just the resources to attack, but they would have learned from the Germans' use of combined arms. This was properly the first time that the Russians used combined forces. So air attacks met by then huge artillery bombardments. Then the armor goes in and then the infantry
跟进。他们以前没有这样做过。这是这一切第一次奏效。配合得天衣无缝，取得了惊人的成果。具有讽刺意味的是，在苏联人发动这场梦幻般的钳形攻势的11天前，希特勒曾在慕尼黑的啤酒馆里站在他的老战友们面前，基本上告诉他们，斯大林格勒已经结束了。我们，我们
follows up. They hadn't been doing that before. This was the first time that it all worked. It clicked, and it had incredible results. So Hitler, ironically, 11 days before the Soviets launched this fantastic kind of pincer operation, he has gone in front of his old fighters in the beer hall in Munich, and he's basically told them them Stalingrad is finished. We've, we've,
我们在进行最后的清剿，这座城市已经是我们的了，不是吗？是的。显然，一直笼罩在斯大林格勒战役最后阶段——那种可怕的最后几周、实际上是最后两个月——上空的那个问题就是，
we're just mopping up with, with the city is ours, hasn't he? Yes. And obviously the question that's always hung over the last, sort of the horrendous last weeks, last two months, really of the battle of Stalingrad is the,
第六集团军。他们几乎马上就知道了。他们被合围了，不是吗？他们说，我们现在应该突围出去，向西突围，同其余的德国部队会合，还是我们就呆在这里死守到底？希特勒说，嗯，你们绝对得呆在那儿，绝对不能撤退，要展现国家社会主义精神。是的，正好。我的意思是，关于这一点有太多的问题了。这是希特勒意识形态上的盲目吗？他的将军们难道不知道这是愚蠢的吗？我想第三个问题是，如果他当时说，“实际上，你知道吗，突围吧，撤回西部，回到大部队身边去”，他们当时真的能做到吗？是的，在那种天气下这也算是个大难题，特别是当你面对如此多的生力军、坦克以及一支焕然一新的空军时。他们可能做得到，但这就只是个假设了：等他们突围出来时，还剩下多少部队。希特勒出了名地不肯承认他们做不到。他为此纠结了一夜。然后他被戈林或戈林的一些后勤指挥官说服了，认为空运是可行的。前一年就已经成功过。所以在巴巴罗萨和苏联冬季反攻之后，一旦希特勒下令坚守阵地，就会有各种孤立的据点。而这些据点曾被
the sixth army. They pretty much know straight away. They've been encircled. Don't they? And they say, should we break out now of the encirclement back to the west link up the rest of the German forces or are we just going to stay here and somehow fight it out and Hitler says well you absolutely have to stay you cannot retreat show national socialist spirit yes exactly I mean there's so many questions about this. Is this Hitler's ideological blindness? Do his generals know that it's folly? And I suppose third, if he had said, actually, you know what, break out, get back to the West, get back to the rest of the troops, could they have even done it? Yeah, that's a big ask in the weather as well, especially when you're
成功地——我的意思是，我们说的是集团军群，而不是几千人，大约有7万到8万人的庞大军队被俄罗斯的反攻合围后，通过空运得到物资补给并打了出去。所以这确实行得通。因此，一方面，他愿意相信戈林对他的承诺——戈林当时正失宠，现在正试图重新博得信任，向他保证说：“我能凑齐足够的运输机来给第六集团军提供补给”——这从一开始就是胡扯。但同样地，正如希特勒向他的参谋长出人意料地坦白的那样，他当时正站在作战室里，指着他们眼下所处的、那个钳形合围已经合拢的态势，指着斯大林格勒说：“如果我们从那里撤退，我们就再也回不去了。”
up against so many fresh troops and tanks and a revitalized Air Force Two. They probably would have done it, but it's speculation on how much would be left by the time they've done it. Hitler is famous for not saying they couldn't do it. And he slept on it overnight. And then he's persuaded by Goering or some of Goering's logistical commanders as well, of that an airlift was possible. And it had worked the year before. So once we had the, after Boba Rossa and the Russian winter counteroffensive, there had been various pockets that had been isolated once Hitler had said, stand and fight. And these had been
他足够清醒，知道为了打到那里所付出的代价，他将再也没有机会重新夺回它。伊恩，那么他们究竟还有什么可能的结局呢？因为他们无法坚守下去。还是说他另有想法？还有另一支军队，不是吗？所以还有南部的军队。但同样地，我认为那更像是一个姿态，而不是一个具体的计划。我不认为这曾经是一个现实的选择。所以这就是“冬风行动”，对吧？
successfully, I mean, we're talking army groups, not a few thousand men, huge armies of about 70 to 80,000 men that had been surrounded by the Russian counter-offenses had been resupplied and fought their way out. So it had worked. So he, on the one hand, he wanted to believe what he was being told by Goering, who had been out of favour and was now trying to get back in favour, who was promising him, I can get together enough transport planes to supply the Sixth Army, which was bogus from the start. But equally, as Hitler surprisingly admitted to his chief of staff, he was in the operations room and he's pointing to obviously where the situation where they're in at the moment, this pincer's closed, and he's pointing to Stalingrad. He said, if we retreat from there, we are never getting back there.
是的。指挥官是冯·曼施坦因，他因率领第11集团军成功征服克里米亚而被晋升为陆军元帅。他随后被空降到这里，就像他在战争期间的其他后续行动中一样。他是一位能力极强、才华横溢的指挥官。他获得了几个新鲜的师，以及一些侥幸撤退到西部并从合围中逃回防线的残兵败将。这些部队被用来试图拼死杀开一条血路。
He was a realist enough to know that the cost that it had taken to get there, he wouldn't be in the situation to get it again. What's the possible endgame, Ian, though, in which they, because they can't hold out? Or does he think? There's the other army, isn't there? So there's the army to the south. But again, I think that was a gesture more than a specific plan. I don't think it was ever a realistic option. So this is Operation Winter Storm, is that right?
他尝试了。行动始于12月12日，但同样，他们只是没有充分估量A，俄罗斯的冬天，以及B，他们现在面对的军队力量。因为他们穿的鞋都不对。噢，不，但到完成合围时，俄国人已经刻意调入了新鲜的增援部队来真正巩固那条防线，防线从斯大林格勒向外朝德国人建立的新前线张望，而包围斯大林格勒的部队则负责将其压缩。所以他们现在处于这个——这叫什么来着，锅釜？
Yeah. And that was von Manstein, who'd been promoted to field marshal because he'd successfully conquered the Crimea with the 11th Army. He was then parachuted in, as he would be in future operations through the war. He was a very able, talented commander. He was given a couple of fresh divisions and some battered survivors that had managed to retreat west and get back to the lines from the encirclement. These were used to try and batter a way through.
“凯瑟尔”（Kessel，德语意为包围圈/大锅）。基本上就是一天天在缩小。我想在这一点上，德国人因冻伤、寒冷和饥饿而损失的人员，可能和死于俄国人火力下的一样多。完全正确。是的，好吧，正如我们刚才所说，他们被空军或戈林承诺了X数量的给养和补给。而空军从各个不同战区拼凑起来试图实现这一目标的运输机，是绝对不可能做到的。即使在天气最好的日子里，
He tried it. It began 12th of December, but again, they just weren't appreciative of A, the Russian winter and the kind of forces that they were now facing. Because they were all wearing the wrong shoes. Well, no, but the Russians had deliberately, by the time they'd done the encirclement, they then brought in fresh reinforcements to really solidify that line, looking out from Stalingrad to the new frontier the Germans had, whilst the forces surrounding Stalingrad would then reduce it. So then they're in this, what are they called, the Kessel?
他们运送的吨位也只有第六集团军所需的一半，因为有超过30万名士兵被困在这个“凯瑟尔”里。他们需要生存所需的一切，而不仅仅是武器和弹药。所以你是对的。随后的几周、一直到1943年1月的行动，目的很简单，就是孤立包围圈内的特定区域，
The Kessel. Which is sort of shrinking by the day, basically. And I guess at this point, the Germans are probably losing as many men to frostbite and cold and starvation as they are to Russian fire. Absolutely. Yeah, well, as we were talking about, they'd been promised X amount of provisions and supplies by the Luftwaffe or by Goering. And the Luftwaffe, the transport planes that they tried to scrape together from all different theaters of operations to try and achieve this, it was never going to happen. Even on a good day,
将其分割并孤立这些据点，以便随后能更轻松地消灭它们。这确实让俄国人付出了成千上万士兵的伤亡代价。但他们负担得起。他们负担得起。而且德国人的抵抗依然十分顽强。正是在这一切的中心，伊恩，你会看到那些极其揪心、
they delivered half the tonnage that the sixth army needed because this is over 300,000 men trapped in this Kessel. They need everything that you need to survive, not just arms and armaments. So you're right. The operations that were subsequently then happening over the coming weeks going into 1943 into January was simply to isolate specific areas of the pocket
实际上又有点挥之不去的场景：德国人在过圣诞节。他们设法砍下树木作为圣诞树。他们点燃蜡烛。他们思念远方的家人。他们唱着赞美诗之类的。所以我在
to carve it up and isolate those pockets to then easily reduce them further. It did cost the Russians thousands and thousands of troops to do this. But they can afford it. They can afford it. And the Germans were putting up a good fight. And in the middle of this, Ian, you have these incredibly harrowing,
我为孩子们写的关于二战的书里也写过类似的内容。当时我儿子在读草稿时，他对我——他那时大概八岁——说：“天哪，这是我第一次意识到德国人也是人。我甚至有点同情他们了。”但你确实会有这种感觉——很难读到这些内容——每当我们读到斯大林格勒战役的故事时，由于显而易见的原因，德国人在我们的想象中就像是反派。但当你读到那些关于他们满眼泪水试图庆祝圣诞节的故事时，
actually kind of oddly haunting scenes of the Germans at Christmas. They try to cut down trees, Christmas trees. They light candles. They think about their families back home. They sing hymns and stuff. So I had something like this,
你觉得很难不为之动容吗？还是说我太感伤了？不，我认为这完全正确。这是人之常情。我极其钦佩俄国人所做的事以及他们所承受的一切。但没错，你确实无法无动于衷。如果你像我一样看过一些创作的画作和圣诞卡片。我家里的这儿就有几张，是我跟老兵交谈时他们提供的。他们非常友善地把这些送给我。它们看起来是如此甜美、惊艳。但显然，在它们背后一定隐藏着恐惧和绝望的故事。我从弗里德里希·罗斯科（Friedrich Roscoe）上校那里得到的个人文件——他显然负责指挥位于这一切中心、在城市中作战的一个团。
about this in my kid kids book that i did about the second world war and when my son was reading the in draft he was he said to me he was then i think eight and he said um god this is the first time i've realized the germans were people too i almost feel sorry for them but you do kind of it's hard to read that i mean whenever we read the stories of the battle of stalingrad for for obvious reasons, the Germans loom in our imagination as it were the villains. But when you read those stories of them, their eyes full of tears, trying to celebrate Christmas,
是的，他是你书中的重要人物之一，对吧？同样，这太令人心碎了。他讲了一个令人惊叹的故事：有一天他站在指挥部门外，并没有告诉部下今天是他的生日。在短暂的寂静中，俄国人暂停了几个小时的炮轰。他们出来呼吸一点新鲜空气，抽根烟，他和军官们交谈着。
do you think it's hard not to be moved or am I being too sentimental? No, I think it's absolutely right. It's human nature. I hugely admire the Russians for what they did and what they suffered. But yeah, I mean, you can't help it. And you look at, like I have, you look at some of the drawings that were created, the Christmas cards. I've got several at home here that were supplied to me when I was talking to veterans. Very kindly, they gave them. They look so sweet and amazing. And they obviously, behind them must be a story of terror and despair. The personal papers I got from Colonel Friedrich Roscoe, who's obviously in charge of a regiment that was in the centre of all this, in the city fighting.
然后，他开始听到该团军乐队对他的小夜曲——军乐队已经洗漱干净，穿上了最好的衣服，从地下室列队行军出来，为他唱生日快乐歌。
Yeah, he's one of your big characters, isn't he? Again, it's heartbreaking. He tells an amazing story of how he's standing outside his headquarters and he hadn't told his men it was his birthday. And amid the silence, the Russians stopped for a few hours of a barrage. They get out and get some fresh air and they're having a cigarette and he's talking to his officers. And he started to be serenaded by the regiment's military band, who've scrubbed and donned on their best clothes and come marching out of the basement and sing him happy birthday.
他感动得热泪盈眶。当你读到这些时，你禁不住会为他们的困境感到难过。但他们确实杀了很多很多的人，让我们记住这一点。所以，好吧，在我们在掏出小提琴（表示过度悲伤）之前，可能还是需要一点平衡。但俄国人也——这正是我们刚才说的掏出小提琴的事。我本想说俄国人搬出了大喇叭，对吧？而我认为最令人难以置信、最阴险的事情是，
And he's moved to tears. And when you read that, you can't help but feel sorry for their predicament. But they had killed a lot of people, let's bear that in mind. So, well, just probably a bit of balance there before we get the violins out. But also the Russians have put up the – that was the talk about they get the violins out. I was about to say the Russians have the loudspeakers out, don't they? And what I always think is the most unbelievably sinister thing,
俄国人放起了大喇叭，播放着时钟滴答的声音，然后有一个声音用德语说：“每过七秒钟，就有一个德国人在斯大林格勒死去。”天哪，太阴险了。而且，那一定非常吓人，你知道的，因为有时钟的滴答声，还有一直在倒计时。反乌托邦式的噩梦。是的，好吧，他们在散发传单。
the Russians have got a loudspeaker playing the sound of a clock and a voice sort of says in German, every seven seconds a German dies at Stalingrad. God, that is sinister. And, I mean, that must have been absolutely terrifying, you know, because the clock ticking and all the time. Dystopian nightmare. Yeah, well, they were dropping leaflets.
他们在利用他们抓获的、愿意发表演说或呼吁战友投降的战俘。到了最后，就像任何巨大的惨剧一样，无论是泰坦尼克号还是别的什么，总会有人在最后关头做出可怕的事。事实也的确如此。这种心理战奏效了。它说服了成建制的部队突破防线，径直穿过雪地走入俘虏营。好吧，我想我们应该在这里休息一下。等我们回来时，
They were using POWs that they captured that were willing to make speeches or call to their comrades to come over. And towards the end, very much in any kind of huge human disaster, whether it's the Titanic or whatever, you get people that do dreadful things right at the end. And there were, I mean, that's what happened. That kind of psychological warfare worked. It convinced whole units to break the line and just walk across the snow into captivity. Okay, I think we should take a break there. And when we come back,
他们利用俘虏来发表讲话或呼吁战友投降。到了最后关头，就像任何巨大的灾难一样，无论是泰坦尼克号还是其他什么，总会有人在最后关头做出可怕的事情。事实确实如此，那种心理战发挥了作用。它说服了整支部队放弃防线，直接走过雪地走进战俘营。好了，我想我们该休息一下了，等我们回来,
let's have a look at how the Germans surrender, their official surrender. And also, I think we should look at how the battle is seen today in Russia and elsewhere in the world. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. today in Russia and elsewhere in the world. Add free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets. Head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Before the break, we heard how the German defeat in Stalingrad was looking inevitable.
让我们来看看德国人是如何投降的，也就是他们官方的投降。同时，我认为我们应该看看今天在俄罗斯以及世界其他地方是如何看待这场战役的。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩下的都是娱乐》。今天在俄罗斯和世界其他地方。享受无广告收听、独家加更节目以及优先购买现场门票的特权。请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《剩下的都是历史》。在中场休息前，我们听到了德军在斯大林格勒的战败已成定局。
But Ian, the first official ultimatum of surrender, so that's official ultimatum sent by the Soviets, by the Red Army High Command to the Germans, comes on the 7th of January. Have I got that right? Yeah. Paulus is feeding this back to Hitler in Supreme Headquarters and they're being discounted one after another. This happens a few times. so there's still communications i mean how are the communications holding up oh they had radio
但是伊恩，第一份官方投降最后通牒，也就是苏军、红军最高统帅部向德军发出的官方最后通牒，是在1月7日发出的。我没记错吧？是的。保卢斯把这个情况汇报给希特勒的最高统帅部，他们一份接一份地不予理睬。这种情况发生好几次。所以他们仍然保持着通信，我是说，当时的通信是怎么维持的？哦，他们一直都有无线电
communications all the way through until the second to last day of the surrender right uh because that's how uh paulus was then promoted to field commander that's how they they gave him his promotion to field field marshal and there's a whole welter of promotions to the various officers. which, you know, Pallis says, this is basically indication I should commit suicide. I should kill myself.
通信，直到投降的前倒数第二天，对吧？呃，因为这就是呃保卢斯后来被晋升为战地指挥官的方式，这就是他们授予他陆军元帅军衔的方式，还有对各个军官的一大堆晋升。你知道的，保卢斯说，这基本上是一个暗示，暗示我应该自杀。我应该了结自己。
So there's that. And it's just the intense, the intensity and the hopelessness of their situation as the ring, the Kessel ring is shrinking as it's then broken up into three specific parts, north, center and south and the communication between those elements are lost and it's what you do and all the time you've got stragglers moving into these these last uh fortifications trying to seek shelter trying
所以情况就是这样。这只是他们处境的紧张、激烈和绝望，因为包围圈，凯塞尔包围圈正在缩小，然后它被拆分成三个具体的部分：北部、中部和南部，这些部分之间的通信中断了，这就是你所做的一切，而且你一直都有零星的溃兵涌入这些最后的堡垒，试图寻找庇护，试图
to get away from the cold medical attention trying to get something to eat so so ian um hitler basically wants them to die like the Spartans at Thermopylae. But what actually happens? Talk us through what the endgame is. Well, the endgame, you're right. He wants them to tie down as many Soviet forces as possible because then it was a strategic matter. He still had to try and extricate Army Group A from the Caucasus,
逃离严寒、寻求医疗救助、试图弄点吃的。所以，伊恩……希特勒基本上希望他们像温泉关的斯巴达人那样战死。但实际情况是怎样的呢？给我们讲讲结局是什么样的。嗯，结局，你说得对。他希望他们尽可能多地牵制苏联军队，因为当时这是一个战略问题。他仍然不得不试图将A集团军群从高加索撤出来，
which were in danger of being sealed off if the Russians pushed even further west from where they were surrounding the Stalingrad area. They could easily shut the door on Army Group A, and then he's got an even bigger disaster on his hands. So strategically, it was thought if powerless can keep going for as long as possible, it ties up several armies that are surrounding Stalingrad and that flank and allows Manstein to extricate as many troops and armor as possible, which is what happens. And he managed to stabilize the front.
如果俄国人从他们包围斯大林格勒的地区进一步向西推进，A集团军群将面临被切断退路的危险。他们可以轻而易举地关上A集团军群的大门，那样的话，他就会面临更大的灾难。因此，从战略上讲，人们认为如果保卢斯能尽可能长地坚持下去，它就会牵制包围斯大林格勒及其侧翼的好几个集团军，并允许曼施坦因尽可能多地撤出部队和装甲部队，事实也确实如此。他成功稳定了前线。
But in Stalingrad itself, yes, it was ground down remorselessly. There's tank armies coming in all directions. And don't forget, there's Chucov's 62nd Army still in the heart of the city, fighting for all it's worth to tie down whatever of Paulus's forces wants to carry on the fight. And there were, there were quite a few thousand troops that were still prepared to go down fighting to the last bullet, as Hitler wanted them to. He wanted everyone to do that, but they still prepared to go down fighting to the last bullet, as Hitler wanted them to. He wanted everyone to do that, but they were prepared to do that. And that's what I capture in Roska's memoir,
但在斯大林格勒本身，是的，它被无情地消磨殆尽。四面八方都有坦克部队涌来。别忘了，崔可夫的第62集团军仍然在市中心，竭尽全力地战斗，以牵制保卢斯手下任何想要继续战斗的部队。确实有，有数千名部队仍然准备战斗到最后一颗子弹，正如希特勒所希望的那样。他希望每个人都这么做，但他们确实准备战斗到最后一颗子弹，正如希特勒所希望的那样。他希望每个人都这么做，但他们确实准备好了。这就是我在罗斯卡的回忆录中捕捉到的，
as in he was just an excellent combat commander, and he was the one who put the backbone into that central pocket where Paulus was housed. And Paulus actually came into his headquarters and took it over as the six armies headquarters but in charge of the actual perimeter and giving the day-to-day orders was uh rosca and this is a department store yeah the univer univer mag department store so really it's like something from a i mean funnily enough pavlov's house that we talked about earlier i know has been in a video game.
就好像他只是一名优秀的作战指挥官，正是他为主保卢斯所在的那个中央据点注入了骨干力量。保卢斯实际上来到了他的指挥部并接管了它，将其作为第六集团军的指挥部，但负责实际防线并下达日常命令的是罗斯科，这是一个百货公司，对吧？是的，环球百货公司。所以这真的很像某种……我的意思是，有趣的是，我们之前谈到的保罗夫之家，我听说它曾出现在电子游戏里。
It's been in a level of Call of Duty, I think. That's right. And the idea of fighting in the shattered remains of a department store surrounded by this bombed out city centre. I mean, that's very Call of Duty, isn't it? I mean, that's literally what's happening. They're reduced to this department store. Well, it's a scene from hell.
它曾出现在《使命召唤》的一关里，我想是的。而且，在被炸毁的市中心包围的残破百货公司废墟中战斗的想法，我的意思是，这非常《使命召唤》，不是吗？我的意思是，这简直就是正在发生的事情。他们被逼到了这个百货公司里。嗯，人间地狱。
And I agree with Tom, it's a hell of their own making. But it's a scene of hell because you've got thousands of dead and dying lying in the basements of this department store. And don't forget, right from the beginning of the battle, that had seen some of the most brutal fighting in and around the department store, around the square where it was based and nearby the train station. That's where the first really titanic struggles were between troops fighting hand-to-hand combat in the buildings and cellars. So fast forward four months later, it's lunar landscape devastation, and that's their final rid-out. And how does a surrender actually happen?
我同意汤姆的看法，这是他们自己制造的地狱。但这是一个地狱般的场景，因为在这个百货公司的地下室里躺着成千上万具死伤者的尸体。别忘了，从战役一开始，百货公司内部及其周边、它所在的广场附近以及附近的火车站，就经历了一些最残酷的战斗。那是双方军队在建筑和地窖里进行肉搏战的第一次真正的大规模殊死搏斗。所以快进四个月后，这里变成了月球表面的废墟，而这成了他们最后的防线。那么投降究竟是如何发生的呢？
How is it negotiated? Well, the official story is a Red Army lieutenant was the first one to make contact and establish that they were offering terms and they were actually willing to talk about terms this time and they weren't going to be rejected out of hand. And it then went up the chain of command and it got to general level where the chief of staff of the 64th Army, which had been defending the south of the city, he was sent in, a guy called Lashkin. He was in there and he was the one who then sat down with Paulus and him and his officers were visibly shocked by the state of Paulus, emaciated, gaunt, slightly unshaven, uniformed slightly, a bit of a mess,
它是如何被谈判达成的？嗯，官方的说法是一名红军中尉是第一个进行接触并确定他们确实提出了条件，而且这次他们实际上愿意讨论条件，不会被直接拒绝的人。然后这件事层层上报，达到了将军级别，负责防御该市南部的第64集团军参谋长被派了进去，一个叫拉什金的人。他进去了，他就是那个坐下来面对保卢斯的人，他和他的军官们对保卢斯的状况感到明显震惊：骨瘦如柴、面容憔悴、稍微有点不刮胡子、军服有点凌乱不堪，
not really the wherewithal to really understand what was being said. But again, when you read the unpublished memoir of Rosca, it was actually Rosca who was in charge of the first communications. He'd gone out and knocked on a tank and said, we want to now discuss surrender terms, send your party over. And that was the first connection made to the enemy that was only a few hundred yards away from them. And obviously they're surrounded by artillery tanks and heavily armoured infantry.
没有真正的心思去真正理解别人在说什么。但话说回来，当你阅读罗斯卡未出版的回忆录时，实际上是罗斯卡负责了最初的通信。他走出去敲了一辆坦克的车门，说：我们现在想讨论投降条件，派你们的人过来吧。这就是与距离他们只有几百码的敌人建立的第一次联系。很明显，他们被大炮、坦克和重装步兵包围了。
They have no chance. They're barely holding on. But before even Paulus had turned up, it was Rosca who'd announced to the Russian leadership, we have the field marshal in the building. Up until then, they had no idea where Paulus was. And therefore, it was Roska who kind of choreographed what was going on over the next few hours and how the Russians would deal with their surrender,
他们毫无机会。他们勉强在支撑。但甚至在保卢斯出现之前，正是罗斯卡向苏联领导层宣布：我们在大楼里发现了元帅。在此之前，他们根本不知道保卢斯在哪里。因此，正是罗斯卡某种程度上编排了接下来的几个小时里发生的事情，以及俄国人将如何处理他们的投降，
as in no one's going to be shot. Officers to a level can keep some side arms. They're going to be supplied with food. They're sick, will be treated fairly. Whether that happened or not, I'm sure it did. Lots of instances, I'm sure it didn't. Well, all the SS get shot, don't they? And any Russians who were in German uniform to get shot?
比如没有人会被枪杀。一定级别的军官可以保留一些自卫武器。他们将获得食物供应。伤病员将受到公正对待。不管这有没有发生，我相信是这样的。有很多例子，我也相信没有发生。嗯，所有的党卫军都被枪决了，不是吗？任何穿着德国军服的俄罗斯人也都被枪决了吗？
Well, I was going to say the hardcore, there was a hardcore that still fought on for a few weeks after the surrender in the Northern sector. And it took over, I think it was something like 10,000 security troops had to go into the city, the ruins of the city, once Paulus' surrender had been official, to flush out this final nest of survivors who were just not going to give in.
嗯，我正要说的是顽固分子，在北部战区投降后，仍然有一支顽固分子继续战斗了几个星期。我记得大概有1万名安全部队不得不进入这座城市，进入这座城市的废墟中，一旦保卢斯的投降正式生效，就要肃清这最后的一群死不认输的幸存者。
And maybe some of them were SS. I'm not sure. The official records don't say that. But they were going to go down fighting. And I think out of the thousands, I think it was 8,000 to 9,000 were there that had to be flushed out and only 2,000 were captured. But in your book, you say that the prisoners, the SS prisoners and the Russians who've been in German uniform, they just get shot straight off. Yeah, yeah. I mean, there was a lot of that going on wholesale, if not the back of a building or just taking away. There's one point that I capture about, which I hadn't read before, where as Paulus is being put into a staff car to take him to 64th Army headquarters to be the famous filming of him, one Russian recognizes him and marches up to him with a machine gun and just wanted to take him out then and there. And he had to be restrained. And Paulus is visibly shocked by this. So Paulus, he gets taken to Moscow, is that right? And he basically flips. He becomes a communist.
也许其中一些人是党卫军。我不太确定。官方记录没有这样说。但他们打算血战到底。我想在数千人中，大概有8000到9000人必须被肃清，只有2000人被俘。但在你的书中，你说俘虏，党卫军俘虏和穿着德国军服的俄罗斯人，他们直接就被枪决了。对，对。我的意思是，有很多人被大规模处决，如果不是在建筑物的背面，就是被带走处决。我捕捉到一个我以前没读过的细节，当保卢斯被扶上一辆参谋车，准备送他去第64集团军司令部进行那次著名的拍摄时，一个俄罗斯人认出了他，拿着机枪向他走去，当时就想干掉他。他不得不被拉住。保卢斯对此感到明显震惊。所以保卢斯，他被带到了莫斯科，是吗？然后他基本上叛变了。他成了一名共产主义者。
Well, they were taken, the majority of the 90,000 that surrendered were marched into captivity, but you know, march of death for many of them with disease and the cold and the lack of, because again, they weren't expected to capture so many prisoners. They didn't have the supplies to feed them. They could barely feed their own troops. So there was a huge casualty rate and drop off
嗯，他们被带走了，投降的9万人中的大多数都被押送进俘虏营，但你知道，对许多人来说，由于疾病、寒冷和缺乏物资，这是一场死亡行军，因为同样地，他们没有预料到会俘虏这么多人。他们没有足够的物资来喂饱他们。他们勉强只能喂饱自己的军队。因此，在几周和几个月内，
of prisoners within weeks and months. But the, yeah, the elite of the German command were taken to special camps. And it was there over the coming months and duration of the war that, yeah, quite a few of them did flip to the other side. And they realized that fighting for national socialism wasn't what it should be and calling upon their comrades to do the right thing. And Paulus was taken to the Nuremberg trials. He's one of the witnesses. And he ends up living in East Germany, doesn't he? He does, yeah.
俘虏的伤亡率和减员率极高。但是，是的，德国指挥部的精英们被带到了特殊的营地。正是在那里，在接下来的几个月和战争期间，是的，他们当中相当一部分人确实倒戈了。他们意识到为国家社会主义战斗并不是它本该有的样子，并呼吁他们的同志做正确的事。保卢斯被带到了纽伦堡审判。他是证人之一。他最后住在东德，不是吗？是的，他确实住了。
And Roscoe, you talked about, who's one of the central characters really in your book. So he actually stays in it. He's in prison for more than 10 years till 1955. So one of the last people to be released, I think. Is that right? Yes, he was tried. Look at his prison records. He was tried as a war criminal, but many of them were, many of the senior officers were. And he, yeah, he did about 12 years. The early part of
而你刚才谈到的罗斯科，他实际上是你书中核心人物之一。所以他确实留在了那里。他坐了十多年牢，直到1955年。所以我想他是最后一批被释放的人之一。是这样吗？是的，他受过审判。看他的监狱记录。他被当作战犯审判，但他们中的许多人都是，许多高级军官都是。而且他，是的，他大约服刑了12年。早期阶段
which first two or three years was hard labor. He moved around the prison of war archipelago. So he was in Siberia, He was in the Urals. He was down by the Black Sea. And he was in Stalingrad because they used quite a lot of POW, German POWs to rebuild Stalingrad over the next few years. So he came home in the last year of the last transports coming back from the east to West Germany. And he came home to Dusseldorf in the summer of 1955.
的前两三年是苦役。他在战俘群岛之间辗转。所以他在西伯利亚，他在乌拉尔。他在黑海边。他在斯大林格勒，因为在接下来的几年里，他们使用了相当多的战俘，德国战俘来重建斯大林格勒。所以他在从东方返回西德的最后一批运输的最后一年回到了家。他在1955年夏天回到了杜塞尔多夫。
I mean, he met his youngest son he'd never seen before. And that's one of the things I capture. Paulus tells him in the ruins of the Univermag while they're getting bombed, news has just come through on the radio that your wife's had a son. And he has to go off into an antechamber to cry because, obviously, it's emotional news. But, yeah, so he meets his son for the first time. But whatever was going on in his head, whether it's PTSD or guilt
我的意思是，他遇到了他从未见过的小儿子。这也是我捕捉到的事情之一。保卢斯在环球百货公司的废墟中，在他们遭受轰炸的同时告诉他，收音机刚传来消息，你妻子生了个儿子。他不得不走到一个套间里去哭泣，因为显然，这是令人情绪激动的消息。但是，是的，所以他第一次见到了他的儿子。但无论他脑子里在想什么，不管是创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）还是内疚，
or he just couldn't, after everything he'd been through, he couldn't settle down. He sadly committed suicide Christmas Day 1956. I mean, it's incredible when you think 1956, the year that Bill Haley and the Comets are touring Britain, you know, rock and roll, all that sort of thing, that the war is still sufficiently fresh in people's minds. And that the scars of it are still so raw that people are coming home and, you know, taking their own lives because of the traumas they've suffered. But talking of the freshness of the traumas they've suffered. But talking of the freshness of the memories of Stalingrad,
或者他只是在经历了这一切之后，无法安顿下来，他不幸于1956年圣诞节自杀了。我的意思是，当你想到1956年，也就是比尔·海利和彗星乐队在英国巡演的那一年，你知道的，摇滚乐，诸如此类的事情，战争依然清晰地印在人们的脑海中，这真是令人难以置信。而且它的伤痕依然如此生鲜，以至于人们回到家里，你知道的，因为他们所遭受的创伤而结束了自己的生命。但说到他们所遭受的创伤记忆犹新……但说到斯大林格勒记忆犹新，
obviously for the Soviet Union, and then when the Soviet Union falls, Russia as well, Stalingrad is the great victory, isn't it? It's the great crowning victory. Yeah, especially today. I mean, that's the one thing you couldn't ignore it. When I was on my trip, I met several historians there, had dinner with them. We had a really good chat and discussed lots of aspects of the story itself that I'm talking about and of Stalingrad as a whole. And to them, yes. I mean, even if you park Putin to one side and whatever agenda he's setting right
显然对于苏联，然后在苏联解体后，对俄罗斯来说，斯大林格勒是一场伟大的胜利，不是吗？这是一场无上的加冕胜利。是的，尤其是在今天。我的意思是，这是你绝对不能忽视的一点。当我去那里旅行时，我在那里遇到了几位历史学家，和他们共进晚餐。我们聊得非常开心，讨论了我正在谈论的故事本身的许多方面以及斯大林格勒的整体情况。对他们来说，是的。我的意思是，即使你把普京放在一边，不管他现在制定了什么议程，以及他在过去几十年里制定了什么议程，对他们来说，斯大林格勒是伟大卫国战争中发生的事情的基石。与其他城市一样，我的意思是，有十多个这样的城市，但斯大林格勒是第一批被称为英雄城市或被斯大林指定为英雄城市并为此庆祝的城市之一。具有讽刺意味的是，基辅也是其中之一，敖德萨也是。所以对俄罗斯人来说，这真的——我的意思是，我怎么强调它对他们的意义都不为过。当我在那里时，我在一个寒冷刺骨的日子里站在巴甫洛夫之家的外面。气温大约零下10度、零下12度，风寒效应下可能达到零下20度，我正在给这座房子拍照。我一大早就到了那里，以为不会有人。
now, and he has set over the last couple of decades to them, Stalingrad is, uh, the cornerstone of what happened in the great patriotic war. And along with other cities, I mean, there's, there's over 10 of them, but Stalingrad was one of the first cities to be called a hero city or designated a hero city by Stalin to be celebrated as such. And ironically, Kiev's one of them too, and Odessa is as well. And so to Russians, it really, I mean, I can't overemphasize how much it means to them. When I was there, I was standing outside Pavlov's house on a freezing cold day. It was about minus 10, minus 12, probably minus 20 in the chill, taking photos of the house. And I got there really early in the morning thinking no one will be here.
大约是早上九点。我身后站着大约两三百人，他们正在参观，沿着伏尔加河走，给巴甫洛夫之家拍照。正如你所说，多米尼克，我知道它出现在《使命召唤》里，但还有其他东西。孩子们一直在接受关于它的教育。它始终处于俄罗斯军事历史、20世纪俄罗斯历史的最前沿。然而，这里面有一个讽刺意味吗？嗯，有大量的讽刺意味，但其中一个讽刺意味是，伊恩，你实际上同意詹姆斯·霍兰在我们巴芭拉·奥西普播客中的观点，即德国向东和向南的推进无论如何都是注定要失败的？
It was about nine o'clock in the morning. There was about 200, 300 of them standing behind me that were doing the tour, going along the Volga, taking the photos of Pavlov's house. And as you say, Dominic, I know it's in a call of duty, but there's other things. Children are educated about it constantly. It's constantly at the front of Russian military history, Russian history of the 20th century. And yet, is there an irony here? Well, there are loads of ironies, but is one irony, Ian, that, I mean, you actually agree with James Holland in our Barbara Ossip podcast, that the German drive, you know, eastwards and south was doomed anyway?
是的，我的意思是，特别是过了第一年之后，我无法理解为什么他们认为自己可以征服这么多的土地。就是这样。但既然已经发动了，他们还能做什么呢？不，我同意。我的意思是，是的，这就是华盛顿选择（别无选择）。并不是说他们可以说，哦，对不起，我们犯了个错误。让我们重修旧好吧。
Yeah, I mean, I just, especially after the first year, I can't understand why they thought they could conquer so much land. That's the thing. But having launched it, what else could they do? No, I agree. I mean, yeah, I mean, it's Hobson's choice. It wasn't like they could say, oh, sorry, we've made a mistake. Let's patch things up.
但这同样因为他向美国宣战而雪上加霜。是的，嗯，希特勒无可救药，不是吗？是的，但在他们甚至还没发动蓝色方案之前，他就已经促成了自己的垮台。他从战略的角度来看待这个问题，而地上的士兵，你读信件，你读日记，他们确实觉得就是这样。这就是他们的十字军东征。罗斯卡给他的连长的公报，因为他在战役一开始就率领他的团攻占了河流。他是城里第一批到达河边的德国人。
But equally compounded by the fact that he declares war on America. Yeah, well, Hitler's hopeless, isn't he? Yeah, but he's instigated his own downfall before they even launched Case Blue. And he's seeing that from a strategic point of view, whereas the troops on the ground, you read the letters, you read the diaries, they did feel like this was it. This was their crusade. The communique Rosca gives to his company commanders, because he led his regiment to capture the river right at the start of the battle. He's the first Germans on the river in the city.
他向部队发表了一份公报，宣布我们做到了，战争几乎就要胜利了。我们到达河边，就完成了。你就会想，他们在想什么？嗯，伊恩，非常感谢。你的新书《斯大林格勒灯塔：第二次世界大战最大战役中心的隐藏真相》面向所有人，现在已经出版了吗？它将于7月28日出版。
He gave a communique to his troops declaring that we do this, the war's almost won. We get to the river, it's done. And you just think, what were they thinking? Well, Ian, thanks so much. To all the force and your new book, The Lighthouse of Stalingrad, The Hidden Truth at the Centre of World War II's Greatest Battle, is out now? It comes out 28th of July.
太棒了。这就是《斯大林格勒灯塔》。我极力推荐它。它非常具有可读性，但这是一个非常让人揪心的故事。但是，汤姆，我不知道你是否同意，但揪心的故事往往是最好的，不是吗？是的，它绝对是揪心的，而且……你知道，我实际上从来没有——所以我也没读过安东尼·比弗的书，承认这一点真是一件糟糕的事。
Brilliant. So that's The Lighthouse of Stalingrad. I can't recommend it enough. It is immensely readable, but it is a very harrowing story. But, Tom, I don't know if you agree, but harrowing stories are often the best, aren't they? Yeah, it's definitely harrowing and and um i do you know i i'd never actually so i haven't read anthony beaver's book it's a terrible thing to admit i
我真的知道我没看过裘德·洛的电影，我没有在家里玩过《使命召唤》，所以我对斯大林格勒战役的无知程度真的是巨大无比，但是……令人震惊，我知道，我不敢相信你竟然有厚颜无耻的勇气在进行这些承认之后还出现在历史播客中。对斯大林格勒战役的无知程度巨大，但伊恩的书……是的，这很令人震惊。我知道。我简直不敢相信你在做出这些承认后，还有脸出现在一个历史播客里。好吧，不过现在我已经读了伊恩的书，我对一切都了如指掌了。我本来想说一件事，但我给忘了，我觉得这其实非常关键，至于他们是否还会继续推进，
i really know i hadn't seen the jude law film i haven't played call of duty in the house so i really there's the the depths of my ignorance about the battle of stalingrad enormous but um in shocking i know i can't believe you have the effrontery the effrontery to appear on a history There's the depths of my ignorance about the Battle of Stalingrad enormous, but Ian's book. Yeah, it's shocking. I know. I can't believe you have the effrontery to appear on a history podcast after those admissions. Well, but now I've read Ian's book and I know all about it. I meant to say one thing I forgot to say, which I think is really key actually, and whether they still go ahead with it,
我会感到非常惊讶，因为现在正发生着这样的事。我和伏尔加格勒共进晚餐的历史学家们正在发起一场运动，要改变巴甫洛夫之家的名字。我以为你会说把伏尔加格勒改回斯大林格勒。嗯，不，但他们一年中允许在日历上的不同日期为了与战争相关的各种日子称它为斯大林格勒六次。但他们想把巴甫洛夫之家的名字改成阿法纳西耶夫之家，因为他们觉得那是正确的事，所以无论它们
I'd be super surprised because of what's going on right now. The historians that I had dinner with in Volgograd were launching a campaign to change the name of Pavlov's house. I thought you were going to say Volgograd back to Stalingrad. Well, no, but they are allowed to call it Stalingrad six times a year to do with various dates in the diary to do with the war. But they wanted to change the name of Pavlov's house to Afanasyev's house because they feel that's the right thing to do so whether they
现在是否从视线中消失，谁知道呢，也许叫阿法纳西耶夫和巴甫洛夫之家，或者那样太冗长了？那是自由民主党的解决方案，汤姆，那非常非常自由民主党。无论如何，非常感谢，呃，我想我们已经把斯大林格勒战役抛在脑后了，呃，非常感谢大家的收听，也感谢伊恩的到来，我们很快就会回来，带来更多基于历史的——嗯，有趣并不是这个词——各种内容。再见，再见。谢谢邀请我。再见。感谢收听《剩下的都是历史》。若想收听加更节目、抢先体验无广告内容并加入我们的聊天社区，
disappear from view now who knows maybe call it afanasiyev and pavlov's house or is that too wordy that's that's the liberal democrat solution there tom that's very very liberal democrat anyway thanks never so much um i think we have put the battle of salingrad to bed uh thank you very much listening uh and thank you to ian for coming on and we will see you soon for more history-based well fun isn't the word stuff goodbye bye-bye thanks for having me goodbye thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community,
请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《剩下的都是娱乐》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝浮华秀场八卦的固定去处，在我们的问答环节中，
please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A
我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及优先购买现场门票的特权，
we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets
请访问 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请访问 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。